The first and most obvious of
all of the pricing strategies,
is simply to have a paid apper game.
This generally appears like it's
going to be a minimum amount of
revenue that you'll obtain, but
the outcome isn't always as clear.
When you're deciding to do a paid app or
a paid game,
make sure that the quality is extremely
high because people are going
to expect this for this type of an app.
If you're just testing out your MVP,
the minimum viable product,
and you don't necessarily know where
it lies on the quality spectrum.
Then you might want to choose
a different modulation method.
With choosing a paid method, so
this is outright paid, it's best
to look at all of the different
types of similarly paid apps or games
to determine the best pricing strategy.
This might vary from country to
country or from time of year.
For instance, if you want to get
a lot of users very quickly and
you're not too worried about
the return during the holidays,
you might want to lower a price point.
If it's during the summer and
you don't really see like a huge rush,
maybe it's a better idea
to price it a bit more.
Of course, having a paid app or
game doesn't mean that
you also can't have IAPs.
Or ads.
But, you have to be extremely
careful not to overdo it on
those types of things, because there can
be push back from your users or players.
There is no best choice between
interstitials that deliver CPC or CPI.
It really depends on what's
converting the best in the end.